- [Man] What are your thoughts
on ideas and strategies
to get the mainstream celebrity
pop-culture influencer
into Call of Duty league to
grow the awareness of it?
- Zero.
It's already happening.
If Charlie from TikTok who's
gone from zero to 7.5 million
followers in TikTok in a month.
Boyfriend next year is
a Call of Duty player
that's way better than
paying LeBron a million
to say he's watching the match.
This has been written.
Written.
- [Voiceover] You got your perspective.
(cheering)
Just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
- YouTube, what's up.
So so grateful that you clicked
and you're about to watch
a new youtube video but before you do,
2-1-2-9-3-1-5-7-3-1.
That is my texting community platform.
Doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there
and also access opportunity,
first looks in that environment.
2-1-2-9-3-1-5-7-3-1.
Join it now and now to the video
you've been wanting to watch.
And I'd love to open it up to very,
listen, we're here.
So very specific, whether
it's 101 questions
or very specific or
selfish to your business,
I'd love to answer anything
I can help you with.
- [Josh] Hey, Gary.
Josh Pete.
- Josh.
- [Josh] I got a fun one for you.
- Please.
- [Josh] All I've really
come away from right now,
is I feel like a bad father
because I've been kicking my son
off of his video game system
for the last four years.
I may have destroyed his future.
- I agree.
(laughter)
Likely.
- [Josh] And I'm
terrified about the people
sitting behind me that are
probably about to throw things
at me because they now know that about me.
I'm a business owner, right.
I wanna make sure I make smart decisions
in my business life.
Let's consider this his business life.
What games should I be
pushing him to play right now
so that in five years he's a billionaire?
- How old is he?
- [Josh] He's 11.
- Okay, so 16 year old billionaire.
(laughter)
- [Josh] We can make this happen together.
- So let me say this,
The answer's I don't know.
I'm sure there's a lot of
people here who are deep enough
in all of gaming and casual gaming,
I think all of us can agree,
if you think of Minecraft
from an engineering standpoint
or other things, if
you're really objective,
there are incredible amounts
of game that's out there
that speak to honing your math skills,
your engineering skills,
your intuitive skill.
There's so much value from it.
I would level this conversation up.
There's a lot of parents
in here, grandparents,
aunts, uncles sisters, brothers,
we demonize technology.
In a world where our
children will only live
in a more technology centric world.
The thought that you put writing a letter
on a pedestal today but being on your iPad
for an extra half an hour as
a negative, parents and humans
are inherently in the business
of no, yesterday, fear.
I've two children, ten and seven,
I am uncomfortably
comfortable with them being
in and on technology every
second of their life.
Now, they won't.
Because that's not how
the world works today
but it has been
fascinating for me to watch
the current state of parenting,
A, demonize technology
but then use it to shut their kids up
when they are drinking wine
or hanging out with their friends.
I mean, I've literally,
this has actually happened in
my life because of who I am
and you go with the
parents from the school,
they would yell at me about
social media or technology
but then we're hitting it off
because it's like the second time
the group is getting
together and their kid comes
and they throw the iPad at
them like it's a ninja star
and say, "Go over there."
The parenting hypocrisy in
2020 is laughable at best
and more importantly much like
the parents that did actually
ruin so many kids over the last 20 years
chance to make 10 million
a year being a gamer
who are now $137,000 a
year lawyers and unhappy
or even not 137.
There's some person right
now who was supposed
to be Tony Hawk who was
supposed to be Kelly Slater
aka Ninja before Ninja, the
great pioneer of eSports.
She or he is probably 38 to 45
because that would have been the time
but she was told she has to go to college.
It happens every day and
I couldn't be more counter
to the current political correctness
of parenting with technology.
I beg for you to debate the
world you think your children
will be living in 25 years.
I remind you that over the last every day
that humans have been alive
we have underestimated
humans ability and the
brain's ability to adjust
to the reality of the world.
Please go read the articles
written in newspapers
about the Kaleidoscope.
I'm being serious.
And how the Kaleidoscope was
gonna ruin the human race
because children were
running around Europe
putting their eye in a kaleidoscope
and weren't paying
attention to the real world.
We demonize Instagram feeds.
Parents who laid in bed as
teenagers and went through
Vogue and Seventeen Magazine
and were on three-way chat
with their girlfriends
for seven hours a day,
demonize children going
through Instagram laying up.
It's fascinating and it's
what has led to a lot of
unhappiness in our society.
And I hope that me conversation about it,
one of the great things
of amassing awareness
is it allows you to talk about things
that you truly believe in
that may spark conversation.
We are such lazy parents
today technology bad.
How about let's actually
build self-esteem in our kids
which then will allow them
to deal with everything.
How about that conversation.
Oh but no it's not fun to be accountable.
It's much more fun to blame
the Russians and Facebook.
That's what I think.
- [Woman] We've got a question
back here in the back.
- [Mady] Hi, Gary.
Mady here.
Quick question,
what was a driving factor that
had invest in Call of Duty
as opposed to maybe
eSports that are larger
on the global scale like
League of Legends or Dota 2?
- The relationship with the Wilfs,
the opportunity that was in front of me.
I had opportunities with Overwatch.
I didn't wanna go there.
My own personal intuition
of League of Legends
versus Call of Duty.
Me being comfortable with starting,
back to my miraculous capabilities
of understanding humans,
I'm at my prime with America
I'm getting really
strong in Asia and the UK
and other places but I'm an 11 in America.
I'm a 7.9 in other parts of the world.
So that gave me triple confidence.
The culture.
When I think, when I looked
at who are the 18 year old
basketball players, who are
the 17-year old rappers,
who are the 13-year old TikTokers of today
that I believed subjectively on intuition
would be here in a decade
and what's the relationship
with video games, Call
of Duty is way up there.
So that feels like cultural relevance
for a decade versus not.
That's the answer.
- [Mady] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
I think what's fun about talks
like this is for a lot of you
the way my content is distributed is,
it's me cursing heavily on LinkedIn
or in a 30-second Instagram
where I'm contextual
to that platform.
But I think, at least for
me, and I appreciate the tone
and tenor of this audience,
I'm not guessing out here.
There's a lot more
thinking going on here than
I like to play on the Internet.
And I think for all of you,
I'm starting to amass
enough wins on the board
that me saying that it's
not required anymore
for more people, thoughtful
people, winning people
to be paying attention closer.
I'm definitely not here for my health.
This is not for kicks and
giggles, I believe this is,
sports and music are the easiest bets
for the rest of your life and
watching the evolution of both
I would be dispassionate
if we were talking about Latin trap.
If I was right now talking
about Bad Bunny and Becky G
and Nicky Jam, I would
be equally as fired up.
Because I believe they
are grossly under priced
and Latin culture in the US,
especially within music is at scale.
These people have people just rattled off
have more followers than
your favorite artists.
You just don't know it yet.
And that to me is the game
that will allow me to buy
the Jets and win a Super Bowl.
- [Darren] Hi, Gary.
Darren Glover.
Can you speak on the
importance of the mainstream
culture influencers.
It's fascinating to hear all the analogies
that always pop up
between where sports was
and then how sports became
something crazy important.
But all these relevant sports
figures now that have grown up
with social media and
have two million followers
that play Call of Duty or
Fortnight just as much as
maybe some of the pro eSports gamers.
- I see, you mean the G Jews
or like like other sports stars
playing these games?
- Basically, as you spoke about.
I mean you talk about all the time.
it's relevancy, it's its
culture, it's Bad Bunny.
If Bad Bunny plays Fortnight,
how important is that to Fortnight?
- It already happened.
- [Darren] Exactly.
- The Fortnight event was Ninja and Drake.
It happened.
This is what I keep telling everybody.
This has happened.
You might not have decided to look at it,
you might have not looked
at it from the proper lens
but that's what mate
Fortnight substantially grow.
I know you know that
based on your question
and that's what's gonna,
like I said, I do not know
the event that will make
the Call of Duty League
go to the next spear.
It will be something.
- [Darren] What are your
thoughts on ideas and strategies
to get the mainstream celebrity
pop culture influencer
into Call of Duty League to
grow the awareness of it?
- Zero.
It's already happening.
We don't need to do it.
They play it and love it.
It's happened.
It's just just a moment away.
If Charlie from TikTok who's gone
from zero to 7.5 million
followers in TikTok in a month,
boyfriend next year is
a Call of Duty player,
that's way better than
paying LeBron a million
to say he's watching the match.
This has been written.
Written.
(laughter)
Listen, this is why people
think I predict things
but I keep trying to tell you I'm not.
I appreciate it but it's not deserved.
I'm regurgitating what's
actually happened.
I'm not fucking Nostradamus.
I'm regurgitating what's happened.
I just happen to know where to look.
I might just be willing
to spend the 25 hours,
took a month looking at the
top charts of the App Store
to realize that Yik Yak
was something six years ago
but then disappeared
or that Vine did this,
where Socialcam did that or
Path was supposed to be this
or Barrow was supposed to be
that or Musical.ly did do this
and became TikTok or Path did this.
I'm putting in the work.
Just like I'm watching
YouTube videos of sophomores
in high school right now to
figure out which college players
are gonna matter for Vayner Sports.
It's just work.
People don't take work and
put it into the right places
and they use media outlets
to give them headlines
to form their opinions.
That's the difference between what I do
and what most people do.
I'm actually in the trenches
being an anthropologist,
strategist and actually doing the work
versus what most people do,
which is they allow something
in the middle to consolidate
the information for them and
allow them the bullet points
and the headlines and in that
practitionership is the Delta
that has allowed me the
luxury and the honor
of sitting up here and being listened to.
The work.
- [Man] I have another question for you.
- Yes, sir.
- [Man] So like you
were just talking about
in terms of doing the work
and I mean most people
don't do the work the right way,
within the concept of like
doing the work the right way,
whether you're planning a business
or planning for your life,
how do you view the distinction
between execution and strategy?
How much should you be
planning for your work
versus how much should
you just be doing it?
- That's great question.
For me, first of all the
answer is self-awareness.
It really is.
Because for you and I might be different.
But it's a very important question, right.
Like somebody once said something to me,
he said, "Gary, you know what
I love about VaynerMedia?"
I'm like, "What?"
I was pumped but it was actually a razz.
He goes, "If I told you
to get to the other side
"of that wall, you would 100% get there.
"The problem with Vayner
sometimes is you would,"
and we were in a glass office.
He's like, "You would
run through the glass
"and get cut to get there when you could
"have just opened the door."
He thought he was razzing me.
I was pumped.
I was like,
'cause I got him back in it's fun chess.
I'm like, "Brother, the
reason you're paying me,
"is 'cause you usually pay
people who just sit in this room
"and debate going to the door."
So I'm Pro doing much more than I hear.
I believe a lot of my strategy
comes from the ABCBEFG
testing that gave me the
answer more than me thinking
I can come up with the answer.
However, not having a good strategy
is always a vulnerability too.
But it's a vulnerability of wasted time
that gives you context like
this investment earlier.
I've already won by the bet.
This could go out of business.
The learnings over the
next 36 months ROI positive
for the way I play.
So I think you've got to know yourself.
Because other people are
for, I'm an entrepreneur.
I'm not capable of sitting
down and doing type-A work.
Other people's chemicals are type-A
so for them strategy
might be the strength.
They fear the doing because feedback
and negative feedback is scary.
The reason we have so much unhappiness
in the Millennial demo is
because the current parents
that raised them,
the most interesting dynamic
I see in culture right now
is 48 to 70 year olds judging
millennials when they were
the ones that parented them.
They're the ones who created
eighth place trophies.
I didn't grow up with
They're the ones who decided
that you have to complement
at scale even though it's
not true and thus your kids
know it's delusion and they
become insecure about everything
because they don't know
which one's true or not.
So you have to know yourself.
And I think you have to lean
into what comes natural.
Whether it's the gray
or the black and white.
I only comfortable in
no and question marks.
Many need to do a ton of stuff
before they can make that jump.
If they try to be like me,
they're gonna have anxiety
in the same way that I would have anxiety
to put together a PDF.
No, really.
If you ask me to make a deck right now,
I would fold like a cheap chair.
I'd be like oh do rock, look
over there and run away.
(laughter)
I'm not capable of doing it which is why
I was such an extremely poor student
but luckily for me at a very young age,
I leaned into who I actually
was and went pot committed
and it worked and I want more
of that for everybody in here.
And you don't have to do it my way.
You have to do it your way.
And that's why that's a
very personal question.
But those are the two ways.
But I'm a big fan of doing.
You can't read about push-ups.
People love to use strategy
as a disguise for non-action.
- [Leah] All right, Leah.
- Leah.
- [Leah] Leah Fuller.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
From my perspective, looking
at the history of how sports
in general has worked and how
its ingrained in education
and how it really starts in education.
Thinking about eSports,
when it comes to standing up
some kind of structure,
just like we've given to
or you've given to the Rockers,
bringing that to K12
and higher education--
- We don't need it.
- [Leah] We don't need it.
What's your view of where that starts.
- It starts earlier than the others.
So if you were--
- Three Rolls are playing
versions of eSports
right this second.
- So if you were to give
structure to K-12 education
and higher education as far as teams--
- By the way to your
point, that will happen.
Clearly, even the way
you're asking the question,
you know how many scholarships
are at the NCAA level.
What do you think happens next?
The high school, you know what I mean?
That's already happened.
The more insightful thing
you said is how it happens
and who gets who first and
what I actually just said.
My son goes to school for seven
minutes in his little drive
with me every day and plays Madden Mobile
as a seven-year-old in
those seven minutes.
Really hard to practice your jump shot
on your seven-minute drive to school.
Larry Bird and Magic Johnson
both famously woke up
super early before school
to work on their game.
My son and hundreds of
millions of others will work
on their game in school,
in between school.
Getting the hall pass
to go to the bathroom
to continue the game and
everything in between.
This is going to be the sport.
- [Man] One question I have had is
how are you going to deal with
new iterations of the game?
It's Modern Warfare this year.
Will it be modern warfare?
- I don't know.
Because that's where the publisher
has disproportionate leverage.
I think this sport is
absolutely gonna have
a different dynamic where you
make a team based on the game
and if the publisher changes
the game enough in 24 months
you might not have the right
talent to extract the upside.
So I would argue,
this is actually one of the
things that excites me the most.
My belief is that,
and not that I get to
be the GM or the coach
but being in ownership,
just having the DNA
of being most comfortable
with changing every day
let alone every year.
I feel like that's exciting.
Now, if we win back-to-back championships
and then they change it
and we're still locked in
in contracts with the guys
or girls that got us there,
I may not be as pumped but I
come in two eyes wide open.
I know that that's the variable.
And by the way, all games evolve.
Like the NBA today, I'm
a die-hard Knicks fan
and the last time they
were good in the 90s,
the scores of an NBA game were 86 to 79.
Now Hardin's taking 90 shots a game.
So things evolve anyway.
This one may be a little bit more.
It's not like the core rules.
My intuition is if but more
likely when this becomes legit
that the publisher will be
thoughtful to not make it
so hardcore that teams get broke.
So I'm open for business.
I know what we signed up for.
- [Man] Thank you.
- Yep.
How are you sir?
- [Jeff] Good.
Jeff Tyler.
- Jeff.
- [Jeff] So you grew up a Knicks fan.
- I did.
- [Jeff] You watch
basketball of the outside.
You keep a fan of the
Knicks free sports players.
I mean they may play the game being a fan.
Maybe to learn more or to
understand the game better
or they understand what they're watching.
How does the outside fan
become a fan of eSports
and will sports betting
find its way into eSports?
- Number two, yes.
Betting finds its way everywhere.
Why don't you keep it Jeff just in case
there's a little jamming here.
The 1982 NBA Finals were
on tape delay in America.
Not live.
That's how little interest.
Cable, right?
As you know changed so many things.
The interest in different things.
Everything is based on the
ability to consume it, right?
So when you think about the NFL
not being able to sell out Super Bowl 1.
Football itself not being
a great sport on radio
versus what it was on television,
all of this has ever been is one big game
of media consumption to build
awareness to build interest.
The reason eSports is
what I'm claiming it is,
is predicated on the world
where actual consumption
is and will continue to grow
in, is native to eSports
more than it's native to the other sports.
So it, again, and this
is what's so powerful,
there are so many people
that consume eSports
that are native to the
consumption platforms of Twitch
and Mixer and YouTube, right?
You might not get the
64-year old TV watcher
because occasionally something
may show up on ESPN or ABC
but you completely own
everybody under the age of 25.
It is easier for 13-year
old Charlie today in school
to consume eSports than
the NHL or the NBA.
The end.
I'll give you a great comp.
The reason boxing is no longer,
you know where I'm going,
is you're old enough
to live through the whole
cycle and I am as well.
- [Jeff] Thanks for that.
(laughter)
- But I throw myself
in the same mix, right?
Is and you had, given probably
whatever our age gap is,
you had it even better than me.
I became a boxing fan because
I saw Michael Tyson fights.
Michael Tyson fights on ABC
Wild World Sports and ESPN
before he beat Trevor Berbick
to become the youngest
heavyweight champ 'cause
he was brutal and wild
and it was something.
'Cause I could see it.
He threw his insane popularity,
and for the youngsters in here,
you can't imagine what Mike
Tyson's popularity was in 1987.
It was uncomfortable.
With him and the heavyweight
division going where it went,
as you know and money came
in it all went pay-per-view,
which meant guys and girls like you and I
couldn't watch it on Saturday at morning.
No more ray beam boom boom
Mancini and Sugar Ray.
The real fights were on on
Saturday morning, right?
That was awareness for free.
It went pay,
this was my point about
major league baseball.
Baseball destroyed itself a
decade ago by creating BAM
owning all digital rights and not letting
any of the kids see anything.
If one of us put up a video of
Maur hitting a home run here
they took it down.
So that's why, got it?
Because this has been written.
It's funny, I was an atrocious student
but there was one class besides gym,
that I got good grades
in and it was history
and I never really fully got it and only
in the last two or three
years have I had an epiphany.
I'm like huh, I make so many
of my business decisions
as an entrepreneur completely
predicated on history.
Because history will tell you the future.
And I've done this, so
you'll appreciate this.
if you look at horse-racing
and boxing and then football
and basketball and baseball,
this has been one big game of
what's available to be seen
and what fits the medium the best.
And eSports fits the next medium the best.
That was super smart.
D, let's chop that up.
Let's get that on LinkedIn.
- [Tyler] My name is Tyler Authen.
I'm actually from a market research firm.
Doing pretty good.
We're working with communities
that are trying to build in-person venues.
So they're kind of the
early adopters of maybe
building facilities that
are dedicated for eSports.
It's not so much a challenge,
it's just where things are right now.
Viewership is off the charts
for eSports versus NFL.
It's more people worldwide watch them.
That ratio though of people
who've attended an event,
is 0.0001% of people who've seen it online
versus maybe 40% of people
who watch the NFL maybe
have been to a game.
That's probably high but it's where--
- It's absolutely the
point given the nature
of both of the lineages, the histories
and the technology stacks
that they were built on.
Makes sense.
Keep going.
- [Tyler] Where do you see the
opportunity for live events
and drawing audiences
that are 40 plus thousand.
- High.
I think it's a foregone
conclusion and I'll tell you why.
When you look at some of those,
it's nowhere at scale to your point yet
but if you look at some of the indicators,
those early things, Madison Square Gardens
fastest sellout event, right?
It's there.
It's there and obviously
one thing that Americans do
very poorly is look outside of America.
South Korea can show you this at scale.
So it just needs more broad interest.
The education of the parents
is going to be enormous.
As we continue to see
videos like we just saw,
a lot of parents are gonna realize,
"If I wanna connect with my kids,
"I need to take them to
this instead of that concert
"or what my favorite sport is."
That will happen.
And the leagues themselves
have to get their act together.
We haven't had organized leagues.
We've had one-off events,
we've had micro events
but this again, UFC's
a great comp for this.
It was very the way it was
and then it got consolidated
proper media attention,
proper story building,
a couple of superstars and away you go.
The fact that we have Bugga and
Ninja already, this early on
speaks to where all the pieces are there.
So I just think this is
just a matter of time game.
- [Tyler] I know you
don't make predictions
but if you had to guess the
timeline is there a chance
the Rocker ever plays in US
Bank Stadium in 20 years?
- In 20 years, 100%.
in five, that's where it gets challenging.
But all you need is,
what's amazing about something
that's already happened,
is you just need one event.
Snapchat, because we've
all lived through this
in the last half decade.
Snapchat happened already
but it took DJ Khaled
getting stuck in the ocean on his jet ski
to get everybody to
know Snapchat happened.
This league has happened already.
It might be one clip of one interaction
between Minnesota and Chicago
where the intensity went
and two of the players
got mad at each other
and punched each other in the face
that hits the social
consciousness which then shows it.
And that's why I don't know.
I know it's done.
I know I'm invested long.
I don't know the spark.
It was Ashton Kutcher challenging CNN
to get to a million first
that made everybody know
what Twitter was even
though it already happened.
Khalid on Snap.
I don't know what's gonna
happen for this league,
I just know it's gonna happen.
I think all of us here
at some level know Bugga
winning 3 million
dollars in one tournament
helped a lot of people that
didn't know know real quick
because that made AP national news.
Something's gonna happen.
Michael Strahan's gonna talk about it on
Good Morning America and
then the process will start.
That's America.
- [Tyler] Thank you.
- [Tom] Hey, Tom Ferrara.
- Hey, Tom.
- [Tom] So my question
is related to something
that you mentioned a little bit earlier
which is one of the
roadblocks is media dollars.
So we're seeing a lot of
participation in eSports
up to maybe even 80% is
sponsorship and partnership dollars
I think that makes sense
for a lot of reasons.
It's really close to
what you would do with
like a traditional sports team deal.
There's a lot of reasons
why you'd want access
to this audience now but
as soon as that turns into,
and this is something I face personally,
conversations with media departments,
they tend to not be in
the know on this stuff
and they wanna apply very
traditional media metrics
for valuing how they're
gonna buy or promote content
or exposure or activations
in the eSports space
and that's become a huge roadblock.
What are your approaches or
advice or recommendations
for trying to get that--
- Fortune 1,000 companies need to fire
their media agencies of record.
(laughter)
Listen, think about
what you're just saying.
You're 100% right and
the reason they do that
is they make much more money
in buying traditional other things.
Media agencies love their
black boxes of programmatic
because they're making tons of,
this is the business I'm
actually in full time.
It's a very easy answer.
It's the same thing I have on social.
It's why so many brands are
declining in market share.
The vested interest of
the six holding companies
media departments and their clients,
are completely in opposite directions.
90% of the media spent
in America is being spent
through a media agency that
is a publicly traded company
that is trying to maximize
its own margin every 90 days.
How in the world can that
be a good service provider?
So what's gonna happen?
One of two things: one,
we will continue to see
direct to consumer
brands that don't follow
the same playbook continue
to tap into market share
until the point of the
Kelloggs and the Unilevers
and the PepsiCo's gets so hurt
that they'll finally wake up
and change their positioning
on how they work with agency partners.
- [Tom] So really it's a first
mover advantage to anyone
who can find a way outside of
that traditional media model?
- That's right.
Or you scare your current age.
What real life is you have enough juice
to go to your current
agency Starcom media share.
all those players and say,
"If you don't do this,
"we will put up your business for review
"because this is strategically
where I want to be."
Because I've never seen in the
history of my business life
and I'm an entrepreneur and
around a bit and I've been,
I'm fast so I've done a lot.
In 22 years, I've never seen
the dynamic where the client
feels like the not client
in the relationship
between brands and their media agencies
because of the contracts that they sign
that are being done at the highest levels
and it's destroying the
Fortune 5000 brands.
- [Tom] Thank you.
- Yep.
- [Max] Hey, Gary.
My name is Max Minsker.
I run the eSports team for
the Minnesota Timberwolves.
So my question for you is based
on kind of your investment
philosophy in terms of
eSports specifically.
So you've said that eSports
it's kind of over already, right?
It's happened and if you
look at the viewership
and the average age of the audience
and then some of them even
the metrics you were showing
regarding how to capture that audience,
eSports obviously has a big market.
But for you when you're
investing in something
like the Rocker, it's not
like a perfectly diversified
ETF of an eSports portfolio, right?
It's a specific investment
in a specific property.
- Which is highly vulnerable.
- [Max] Exactly.
So my question for you is how
do you take that knowledge
of the industry and the macro
trends that are occurring
and where the audience
is and translate that
into like a micro investment
into one specific property
that might have more
vulnerability and then--
- I think you don't.
I think you need to amortize
out your bets, right?
To your point, the
vulnerability of this investment
which was a hefty one for
me is nobody wants to play
Call of Duty anymore.
I don't know there was,
Frogger was awesome when I was a kid.
(laughter)
Meanwhile, basketball hasn't gone away.
On the flip side, we are now
in the early stages of games
like Madden and 2K and
others that are like
wow it's still here and it's really here.
And Mario and Zelda and
so this is a complete bet
back to the biggest point I
made, Cargo and the Wills,
this is a human thing for me as well.
That's why I took both.
I actually, publicly, I'm
sure we can find video of it,
did not want to invest in
publishing IP team sport.
I just thought it was too vulnerable to,
Ultima Online was a precursor to all this.
I've watched, I've been watching,
this was a move for a lot of reason,
to me this is a franchise that I feel had,
first of all this is a limited franchise.
This is a global sport
but first party shooter
Call of Duty is much more
Americanized than it is Asia
or the other things.
So again, very eyes
wide open going into it.
For me diversifying
comes in a lot of ways.
Vayner Sports is very focused from date,
the day AJ and I started
Vayner Sports which Iona's NFL
sports representation business
we're up 30 football players
but from day one eSports
is the lead second sport
we wanna get into when I
started making this deal,
I had to figure out which
side am I sitting on,
what can I do do, I have
to rep people outside.
So I'm going through all
that but that's huge too.
Look, VaynerMedia as a
creative and media agency
is a thought leader in
strategy around this category.
So as you can imagine me looking forward
the way I'm gonna hedge is I'm
probably gonna have an agency
that's making 30 to 50 million
in in consulting strategy
and creative output fee for helping brands
get into this space better.
I might bring back ice hockey on Nintendo
and be the best player, make
five million a year playing it.
I may invest in whatever
emerges as the chuck-e-cheese
or Buffalo wild wings of this space.
To me this is how I do it.
If you look at all my behavior,
it's why I built Vayner.
I built a communications
Death Star which gives me
flexibility to go into anything.
So 10 years ago when I could have raised
a half a billion dollars on the
back of Facebook and Twitter
and all those great
investments that I made
that put me on the map, instead
of going the real easy route
of high wealth creation
of raise a half a billion,
make 10 million a year to
take meetings and have 20%
of the upside of the bets
off a great track record,
I decided to build an agency
which is a grind, super hard
but I knew I was building the
comms stack to take advantage
of the diversification of macro thesis.
- [Max] So does that affect
how you think about the revenue
you have of this property
on a year-to-year basis?
Because you can diversify?
- Yeah, I don't think about
the revenue of this business
on a yearly basis at all.
Just make payroll.
Don't go out of business.
When you bet long and in perpetuity,
we live through a time
now where everyone's
building businesses to sell them.
I only build businesses to die with them.
When you do that all you
have to do is just stay alive
when you're betting on
what you know is right.
- [Andre] Good.
Andre Bortnaav with Obsedian group.
Hi, Gary, nice to meet you too.
First time.
- Thank you.
- [Andre] Quick question for you.
- First seeing--
- [Andre] Seeing you,
consume your content.
Kind of maybe this is maybe
more of a macro question
but in terms of marketing
strategy and consumer attention,
what would be the difference
or is there a difference
between eSports and traditional sports.
On what platforms do you
think eSports would dominate?
Thanks.
- No, question.
Hold on to the mic just in case.
So there's a lot of differences.
First of all I believe that eSports even
with the macro league deals
or title deals or team deals
is grossly under priced in
comparison to the price you pay
in traditional sports because
they are a mature asset
and what they want in
return for step and repeats
and patches and integrations
is so much more expensive
even though these numbers
are not small anymore
because the audience is there
but still paying for an NHL
integration and you're trying to reach
15 to 30 year old males,
you're gonna get ripped off
in the NHL in comparison to eSports
just on the sheer attention.
As far as platforms, to your point,
and this was to the gentleman
behind you that I'm looking at,
this sports' ability to be 100%
native to Twitch and YouTube
and Instagram and thinks that
nature is a huge advantage.
I mean the NHL watched
baseball do the wrong thing,
was losing relevance and
then signed a deal with BAM.
I mean, there's not a person,
we're in Minnesota and I think
the majority of this room
would struggle to name
10 hardcore all-stars
outside of wild players.
It's a mistake.
Anyway, nonetheless, I think that,
look at the NBA.
The NBA takes far more of
a superstar build brand,
we know more six men on NBA
teams than we know all-stars
in the NHL and Major League Baseball.
So I think that,
one, I think it's under priced.
I think if you you call
Rocker and you call the Wild
and you try and your
focus is a certain demo.
Now, if your focus is $200,000 income,
52 to 75 male middle
America, then all of a sudden
I wanna talk hockey.
So it depends on your
strategy but the reality is
some things are just grossly under priced.
And I think for the next half
decade there'll be a lot of
arbitrage opportunities for association
with what happens in this sector.
Whether in this league, the platform's,
the individual humans.
I talked to Tyler, I talked to Ninja.
In his first deals, he
gets paid a lot more now
than he did then.
You were stealing Ninja's
equity in those first 25 deals.
Then he got William Morris
then he became Ninja,
the way we know him and
all of a sudden what used
to be able to get for
free product or $10,000
becomes $250,000 for five minutes.
The game.
- [Andre] Thanks.
- Yep.
- [Josh] Hey, what's up, Gary.
Thanks man.
My name is Josh.
- Josh.
- [Josh] Three questions, real quick.
First is what happens
when you own the Jets
and your now friendemies
with the Wilf family?
what does that look like?
- I'm going to try to beat their faces it.
(laughter)
Much like the Wilf screw-up
insane over-the-top Giants
fans and I'm sure when
they face the Giants
they're not rooting for the Giants.
- [Josh] Yeah, I hope not.
I hope not.
- Doubt it.
- [Josh] Second question, who's
the most interesting person
you've ever met?
- That's interesting.
I would say the most
interesting meeting I ever had
was with Mark Zuckerberg
when I spoke to Facebook
when they had 200 employees.
I didn't know him.
Obviously Facebook was starting to roll.
I spoke to the company.
I didn't know he was in there.
He was way in the back.
He came down he asked me,
I had a flight right after
the talk and he goes,
"How long are you in Palo Alto?"
And I was smart enough to be like,
"Oh I'm leaving tomorrow."
Then he's like, "You wanna have dinner?"
I said yes and I'll never forget this,
obviously Facebook was already huge
even though they were a
small amount of employees.
We had dinner and I remember thinking,
I believe that I am a
one-dimensional player.
I believe that I understand
human being so well
that every other aspect of
what I do I'm average at
but I'm so remarkable at
consumer behavior and being,
by the way when I deliver
something like I'm so remarkable
complete luck of the draw
of mom and dad having sex
at the right moment,
complete natural luck of,
I take no pride and I love
giving the daps to my parents,
I love giving the daps to my circumstance
but I'd never met somebody in
my life up until that point
that I thought was deeply
and utterly consumer
blindly human-centric.
I am an extrovert and
an outward personality
so one could kind of make
an assumption to that.
He is a technologist and
introverted and even I'm sure
when you've seen him on
Capitol Hill or other places,
that would stun you
that is his great suit.
To this day, not President
Barack Obama, not Bill Clinton,
not many other people that you know,
I've never sat across from
somebody that I felt Jedi like
"Oh, wait a minute, you know too."
And makes sense that's
why he built Facebook.
- [Josh] That's awesome
and a perfect segue
to this last question.
What's the most badass
Jedi book you've ever read?
- Read?
- [Josh] Read, yeah.
- So I've read like four books in my life
and I would have to say the
biography of Barbara Walters.
I actually believe that
Barbara Walters may be
one of the most underrated
contemporary personalities
of the last 50 years.
I know you didn't see that one coming.
(laughter)
- [Man] Hey, Gary.
Glad good to see you again.
Very excited have you on
copy closes next year.
So here's my question.
You were talking about
being ahead of the curve
and where this is headed I
think we've all been convinced
this is a very exciting
time to see where this goes.
Are there any, for the average investor,
are there any products
or companies right now
that you could list off that we should be
paying attention to or investing in now?
- The answer is I'm sure I
haven't done the homework.
So the answer is, I don't
know but I do think this is a,
I will give you an answer
that maybe helps you bring
some insight that might help you.
Always look at the picks and the shovels.
I'm very vulnerable with this
hefty seven-figure investment
because if this title is in
contemporary in 15 years,
I'm vulnerable.
Picks and shovels.
Got it?
So whether it's private public
market or something else,
pay attention to people that
are building infrastructure
around this movement evergreen
not at the mercy of Twitch or
you like that?
(woman speaks in the crowd)
Thank you.
Thank you and I appreciate that.
It's a really important insight.
A lot of us will gamble or I
don't feel this is a gamble.
What I'm gonna learn over
the next three years,
is gonna do more for
me than the investment
whether this exists or not.
The people that I'm
gonna be associated with,
the learnings, practicing
to be an owner, that stuff
but it was only five minutes
ago that a $25,000 check
was very scary for me to bet and with what
and what I tried to do
was bet on what I knew
or what had already happened
or picks and shovels, right?
Look at search engines and browsers.
Infrastructure, right?
So what's the infrastructure,
what doesn't rely on
it being Fortnight or
Call of Duty or Activision
as a business that can
just flow if in four years
it is Frogger or there's two
girls in Nashville right now
inventing an IP that becomes
the game for ten years.
How does that company
take advantage of that
versus get hurt by it
in perpetuity evergreen,
picks and shovels.
- [Joe] I have a question for you.
So Joe McIntosh and first
of all Nintendo ice hockey,
three fat guys.
One, Skinny, I don't
think you can touch me.
- Let's go.
- [Joe] I don't think you can touch me.
- Bro, if you find yourself
in New York, no kidding,
it's Gary VaynerMedia let's go.
- [Joe] The other question I have is--
- By the way to give him
daps, the three fat one skinny
is my line up too.
I'd be lying if I didn't say this guy
knows a little something.
By the way for anybody who doesn't know
what we're talking about,
the way the game starts is
you get to pick your team.
You pick your team, it's Olympic style.
I'm always Russia because I
was born in the Soviet Union
and then you get a skinny,
a fat or a medium guy
and four spots and you kind
of and put it together.
The hack is three fat guys and a skinny
so I'm a little bit worried about Joe.
(laughter)
Makes sense Minnesota hockey culture.
All right, brother, I see you.
- [Joe] So my question is,
I'm sitting here listening
to you talk and I feel like,
"Man, anything this guy touches seems like
"it would turn to gold."
It's just like you have this
energy, you have this passion
and I'm thinking about
myself and my world.
How can I bring that same
energy, same passion,
see, I sell widgets, right?
And I sell widgets the 65 year old men.
It's like they're clueless about the
to what's going on in reality,
the 26-year-old and below.
I'm just like how would approach that?
- Well, couple things
to talk about with this.
One, they may not have
to worry about it, right?
So for example you've
heard me mention TikTok
a couple of times.
That the other platform in
the world of marketing today
that I'm obsessed with is LinkedIn.
LinkedIn's organic reach
is so uncomfortably high.
It's Facebook 2012 and as you can imagine
and I see the body language
here you're clearly gonna reach
different people on LinkedIn
than you are on TikTok.
And that 65 year old male decision-maker,
I don't know when he or
she is buying that widget,
are they actually
targeting 15 to 35, right?
So to me it's funny, I'm very
fortunate in the fact that
my passion is agnostic.
All I do is day trade
attention and behavior
and it's a very important sentence.
It's day trading.
How many people here
follow me pretty closely
on social just for context?
So, thank you so you
noticed over the last year,
I've done a lot of recall
videos on Instagram
where I show you me
saying something in 2008
and showing it again like
that's back to not guessing.
You get the equity of reputation.
I'm not just jumping on now, I was right
but it wasn't predicting
it was because those things
had already happened.
The thing I'm most waiting
for is 15 years from now
when I'm completely on social media.
The way I would talk about
print and direct mail, right?
Because I'm not committed to anything.
I'm just pop committed to
the ability to daily, daily.
I wrote my last book which is
how to win on social content
distribute right now.
It's only 18 months old not a
mention of LinkedIn or TikTok.
A couple things,
one, it has to start with the truth.
Are you actually passionate
of selling widgets
in a B2B environment?
To bring, I failed all my classes.
If you told me right now to
hang a picture on the wall
I would jump out the window.
No passion.
Don't wanna do that stuff.
Take out the trash, no.
Read, no.
Write, back to the book.
It starts with self-awareness.
The greatest gift I was
given was conviction
and self-awareness.
I know what I'm good at,
I know when I'm bad at.
My parents built, my mom built self-esteem
so I was able to deal with judgment.
I was a terrible student
during the greatest era
of it meaning to be good
at school to be successful.
I was making $6,000 a
weekend as a 14-year old
and told everyday by my
friends parents and my teachers
that I was a loser.
If I was making $6,000 a weekend
today selling sports cards,
I'd be on cover of
magazines like now we herald
14-year olds making money.
That's the culture now.
Entrepreneurship got cool again.
So, to answer your question, many things.
One, do they even need to
care about these things?
If you're an executive or
you're wrapping up your career
or whatever it has to be practical.
I'm practical.
Number two, you have to
look within yourself.
How old are you?
- [Joe] 43.
- So for me, you and I are part of
a really interesting
generation because we're,
I just turned 44.
Now, I know the skinny and fats, I get it.
You looked younger.
You look good, bro.
(laughter)
One of the biggest things I'm
hoping that I can communicate
to the world through
this newfound attention
is our unbelievable inability
to have a good relationship with time.
Every 22-year-old wants
it to happen tomorrow
and every 43-year-old doesn't
think that they can take
a hard left and completely
start over because they don't
realize they're gonna
live for another 52 years.
Our complete and utter
atrocious relationship with time
is leading to an enormous
amount of unhappiness
and so like I see you and
even just like the energy
and how you ask the question,
I was compelled I'm like bro
you might just need to really
look at yourself in the
mirror tonight and say,
"One step backwards three steps forward."
Happiness has to be the ROI you know.
And I think if you could feel
in your bones another 29 years
of a professional career,
all of a sudden when
you look at it that way
versus I'm 43 and look at all
these kids doing it at 19.
If you look at it as 29 more
years before I even debate
slowing down that all of
a sudden sounds practical
to maybe say I don't wanna
sell widgets anymore.
So that's the stuff that
goes through my mind.
- [Joe] Thank you.
- Yep.
You can imagine you under
30 year olds in here
what I think for you.
So much time.
- [Sam] Gary, Sam
Schwartz from Duke Cannon.
- Hey, Sam.
Yeah, good to see you.
- [Sam] I got a 101--
- Thank you for the swag.
- [Sam] Oh, yeah, I hope you like it.
If you don't, don't tweet about it.
- I won't.
- [Sam] 101 question I'm
gonna ask of baseball history
which I hope you appreciate.
So as you know in the
early days of baseball
there wasn't an MLB a bunch of independent
professional league.
So I wonder about is there
a parallel here whereby,
will there be a bunch of leagues
competing for players and resources--
- Baseball, hockey, football.
Of course, history, yes.
- [Sam] Will there be other,
well a well-heeled
investor come in and start
their own Call of Duty League?
- Yes.
- [Sam] Okay.
So how do we place the right bet then?
- Be consumer-centric.
The USFL would still be operating
if they stayed in the spring.
That's what great about the game.
It's just merit.
wine.com raised $240 million
when I launched winelibrary.com
with $30,000 in marketing.
I won.
Money is not scary, being delusional is.
You like that one?
(laughter)
It's good one.
It was a little gangster.
I like that.
Clip that D-roc.
It's true though.
How many examples do you
want of something super
well-funded not defeating the thing
that was consumer-centric?
I said I'm not a genius.
There's 47,000 examples, google it.
It happens every day of the week
because a lot of times,
I think I've been, the
worst points of my career
is when I've had money in the pocket.
I'm at my best when I don't have it.
Thank you so much for your time.
(applause)